the airfield at kamau in the Delta lands
of South Vietnam drops away as the
helicopters fly to pick up the
Vietnamese Rangers it is the 14th of
September and this is the beginning of
Phase three of operation dong XI 261
troops of the 21st infantry division
Army of the Republic of Vietnam are
conducting the operation to wipe out the
Vietcong in the Delta country of the 4th
Corps area the operation has been going
on for many weeks helicopters of the
u.s. 13th aviation battalion are
providing direct air support
transporting the troops and flying fire
team mission below is the nam cheong
forest some 200 kilometers southwest of
Saigon the Viet Cong are strong here in
the rice fields on the edge of the swamp
and forest the theater amis Rangers get
off and begin filing into the enemy-held
territory moments later a second wave of
choppers comes in and more Rangers
stream across the field in the skies
above army airmen scrutinized the battle
zone and Gunners strafe suspected enemy
positions more than once there is
answering ground fire
over the swampy Kamal river one of the
gunships locates a Viet Cong sampan the
vessel and its occupants are obliterated
by rocket fire finally the helicopters
head home to rearm and refuel one week
later General William C Westmoreland
comes to the helicopter base at canto on
this occasion at the battalion's
headquarters 180 kilometers southwest of
Saigon the commanding general of US
forces in Vietnam is to present the
valorous unit award to the 13th aviation
battalion which is supporting the
Vietnamese Rangers in operation done she
already the most decorated American
aviation battalion in Vietnam the 13th
receives a new streamer for the
battalion flag the citation is awarded
for quote extraordinary heroism and
professional skill in support of the
21st division Army of the Republic of
Vietnam on april four five and six 1965
unquote the unit's commander Colonel
Jack T Dempsey receives the document on
behalf of the battalion following the
presentation the men of the 13th the
only American army combat unit in the
Delta region here a personal
commendation for their numerous
outstanding combat missions performed in
support of the Vietnamese 4th Corps Army
Rangers then general Westmoreland bids
them continued success phase 4 of
operation dong XI 261 gets underway on
24 September as the Arvin 41st and 42nd
Ranger battalions resume their
counterinsurgency campaign in the Delta
at the como Ayer strip the u.s.
helicopters are loaded and boarded by
the Vietnamese troops soon the friendly
forces are airborne toward their
objective in the swamps 20 kilometers
south of come out
gunships lay down suppressing fire along
the perimeter of the basic objective in
the region below the Vietcong have
established training and staging areas
reports indicate a concentration of the
enemy in this sector Rangers of the 41st
battalion are delivered to the landing
zone and immediately strike out for the
presumed enemy positions in the swamps
ahead with armed helicopter support
overhead the Arvin troops advance with
confidence the Rangers of the 41st
battalion sweep into the swamp in two
converging forces helicopters block the
enemy Exodus in a day long battle which
rages back and forth in the swamps the
Rangers exact the heavy toll in Viet
Cong killed and weapons captured armed
helicopters accounted for still more of
the enemy dead
17 kilometers to the west of Kamau
Rangers of the 42nd battalion captured
fifty five members of the famed Vietcong
human too we're looking here to group of
39 of 55 you have just surrendered or
which unit he's a member of he said
there is unit belong of human toe but
they were the new hood who the best man
for human to I see most of these are new
recruits for healing to the men look
like young howls the youngest man could
he tell me that but yeah I don't mind
man oh you're going on 14 years of age
14 what were the circumstances of the
act of recruiting him line it om dear
tower Linda come on i am count on you
old into md now have data for you give
our own lawyer and me down and they yeah
it fit him by kaffir how long have they
been in the service of the Viet Cong man
Emma yo girl Gina but all right seven
day I see how long is the training
schedule to be more than one week more
than one bit but he does not know jus
Allah almost every one of them raised
their hand and they have been in seven
days is a brand new recruits ranging
from 14 years of age and what if the the
age of the eldest recruited by 57
meanwhile Rangers of the 41st battalion
are picked up and flown back to come out
after fighting a pitched battle with the
Communist enemy all day long the Rangers
will rest tonight and return to the
Delta battlefield tomorrow Brigadier
General know and fun min commanding
general of the Arvin 21st division says
quote this is but part of a continuing
operation and we intend to keep the
pressure on unquote the general also
revealed that the number of Vietcong
defecting to the key government each
month is on the increase for this day
there's victory in the devil
elements of the 196 light infantry
brigade recently arrived in vietnam
prepare to launch a search-and-destroy
operation on the seventeenth of
September this is one of the first
sweeps to be carried out by the troops
of this brigade taking place near Tay
Ninh approximately 80 kilometers
northwest of Saigon the operation is
aimed at locating and destroying
Vietcong fortifications here in the
rubber plantation Country of tay ninh
province according to intelligence
reports there are supposed to be a
number of DC positions in the
surrounding area now abandoned these
enemy trenches wind back and forth in
the undergrowth for several hundred
meters tunnel entrances are found every
few steps along the way and have to be
investigated the tunnel runners are
summoned these specially trained
underground men know all of the tricks
to searching enemy tunnels
they reappear in short order they
discarded submachine gun clip and some
viet cong propaganda literature are all
that remains in the tunnel complex these
items quickly brought out for the tunnel
runners it is the first time these
troopers have seen such enemy propaganda
material unit commanders order the
tunnel complex destroyed so the Viet
Cong will not be able to use these
facilities again in the future the men
take cover and the diggings are blasted
following the incident of the trenches
and tunnels the infantrymen move on
until they reach an open field here they
are fired upon by snipers locating the
source of enemy fire some of the
troopers scurry off to flanking
positions from which they return the
Rifleman's fire the sniping stops it is
discovered that the Viet Cong sniper has
been killed the dead enemy is the first
confirmed kill for the 196 here in
Vietnam then the men move out and the
operation goes on
at twe wha a unit of the 100 first
airborne gets ready to escort an
artillery convoy along the stretch of
highway one to the north known as root
purple the convoy of munitions and
supplies is headed for thuy on 45
kilometers away as soon as they pull out
the men are on constant alert for any
sign of trouble convoys along this route
have been hit every few days by VC
ambushes and sniper fire but this time
the convoy reaches thuy on without
incident and after a short breather the
men of the 100 first turn around and
head for home mission accomplished in
another operation an engineer mind
detecting platoon of the 100 first
cautiously sweeps the same area
carefully a suspected area is dug up but
it turns out to be a false alarm and the
column moves on this time however it's
for real a charge is placed atop the
mine the fuse set and the area cleared
of personnel the charge is definite it
further on as the engineers link up with
a convoy of trucks waiting a clearance
snipers open up with automatic weapons
anti tank and artillery support from the
rear is immediately called in
as quickly as they came the enemy with
drawers under the natural cover of dense
foliage the all-clear is given and the
convoy rolls out again
okay today we're having our briefing on
operation Sioux City it's the operation
will be leading on tomorrow and I'll
start the briefing now this is Army
Specialist Bob Owens the united states
army special photographic attachment
pacific five we're with today the 170
third airborne brigade at benoit airbase
in south vietnam yeah d brigade is
preparing to launch into operation Sioux
City another probe into war zone d
lieutenant richard buckles the 3rd
platoon leader of Company D 16th armor
is briefing his men on the mission to
four o'clock in this area we secure this
fire support base intermediate fire
support base while these three 19th
artillery moves into this area to fire a
20 minute preparation on to position
Mohawk which is this area up here this
will be our final five for base and
brigade CP morning we'll have a common
with check at zero five hundred will
also have a panel on your track started
Gary to lead tracks or the other
observers on the air and after that then
we'll be ready to move out starting on
this time life will you take charge of
the man and have them prepare for move
out at 05 3026 September the 16th armor
began transporting troops of Company B
first Battalion 50 3rd infantry starting
off operation Sioux City when the convoy
crossed the Son Doong Knife River it
entered VidCon territory in war zone d
lieutenant buckles what is our
approximate position here and what is
the mission of the unit we are now
located about seven or eight miles
inside diesel position Fox we are
securing the intermediate fire support
base where the artillery which is going
to fire concentration I approximately 20
minutes tune into position Mohawk which
will move into after they finish this
and stuff our permanent far support days
as it prepares to move out from
checkpoint fox the convoy comes under
sniper fire this is answered immediately
afterwards the apc's turn their big 50s
on the heavily mined road ahead blowing
a path through them and the convoy moves
on
7 sep tember it's moving in week 4 the
main body of nearly 4,000 troops of the
11th Armored Cavalry Regiment arriving
at Benoit airfield c-130s have flown
them from their deportation port of
buntao and now these men of the black
horse regiment will be transported by
bus to their temporary base camp at
nearby long Binh at the base camp the
new arrivals join the 400 man advance
party and move into their tents a
refreshments are the first order of the
day served refreshingly by a young lady
from the Red Cross another welcoming
touch is provided by the Red Cross as
the young lady collects messages to be
sent via Marz to relatives back home now
the new arrivals get to work under the
protection of armed security guards a
detail fill sandbags for area
fortifications others and place the
sandbags around newly built bunkers a
converted oil truck provides the
essential water supply for the camp Chow
is a welcome break in the work routine
compliments of the mess sergeant the new
arrivals are kept on their toes by alert
drills the men climb aboard their
personnel carrier the gunner stands
ready and alert and the APC pulls out
then on 24 September the men of the 11th
Armored Cavalry are visited by general
william Westmoreland for an official
welcome Colonel Cobb officers and men of
the blackboard ready this is the first
time that the 11th Calvary has been in
Southeast Asia since 1900 and 155 years
ago your regiment was in the Philippines
involved in the Philippine insurrection
1916 you're involved in the war with
Mexico Jason Fat Joe Vella world war 2
11th Calvary served with distinction
having strong 3 organization at fort
during that war it's now my great
pleasure to welcome the famous black
horse regiment the 11th Armored Cavalry
in Southeast Asia you're in Vietnam
goong-bok end not far from cam ranh bay
is the site of camp d 51 this is one of
the many Special Forces camps set up to
train Vietnamese for the civilian
irregular Defense Forces the classes are
taught by vietnamese regulars but men of
the 5th Special Forces are always on
hand to evaluate the instruction the
student soldiers begin by learning the
operation of weapons and equipment they
may be using in defense of their homes
here they practice assembling the HT one
radio weaponry training at the school
puts heavy stress on the hand grenade at
the nearby range the men get plenty of
experience in the technique of hurling a
grenade for maximum distance and
accuracy
they find it a potent weapon and quickly
learn to take cover after cutting loose
at the rifle range the students get
familiar with a variety of light weapons
such as the ba are under the watchful
eye of Special Forces advisors the men
come from all parts of Vietnam and will
return to their villages when the
four-week course is completed
hand-to-hand combat techniques are an
essential part of the training the men
are not only taught to fight but also
how to fall without injury or loss of
control these men were chosen for
training because they are already
leaders in their villages and will be
better able to pass on their knowledge
to others in the last phase of training
the students begin field exercises the
purpose of this river crossing is to
teach them how to keep their weapons and
clothes secure in their Poncho's
starting to look like veterans the men
learn to camouflage themselves for a
simulated ambush against aggressor
forces when these Vietnamese return to
their villages the VC may be in for a
surprise
on 15 September the initial elements of
the first philippine civic action
battalion arrived attaining airfield 130
kilometers northwest of Saigon a
vietnamese army band strikes up a
welcome as the men marched from their
c-130s to a nearby reception area on
hand for the occasion is General William
C Westmoreland accompanied by city and
province officials who will work with
the unit the 2,000 man battalion will be
concerned exclusively with civic action
projects throughout Tay Ninh Province a
crowd of girls waits to shower the
troops with Garland's of flowers in a
traditional Vietnamese welcome battalion
commander general Gant NCOs focus is
among the first to be honored
after the ceremonies the garland and
troops move out to board a fleet of
waiting trucks and begin their
assignments
on 28 September as pastoral Nuremberg
passes below a train crowded with German
and American troops is on its way to an
80 sports fest in this realistic
exercise a plane plummets into it
exploding the engine in the first two
cars a bouns bond watchman puts in the
alarm an operation Simcoe 66 begins dr.
Andreas ash Lecter Lord Mayor of
Nuremberg explains this day-long mass
casualty exercise is intended to
demonstrate the joint efforts of the
Germans and the Americans in any
emergency the burning and the wreckage
and the screams of the wounded make this
simulated disaster frighteningly real
estate the Nuremberg city fire
department arrives on the scene clad in
their asbestos suits they spray the area
with carbon dioxide as soon as the call
is received reporting the time place and
type of incident medical personnel
ambulances and every available piece of
emergency equipment is rushed to the
scene by city hospitals of Nuremberg and
Firth by the US Army's 20th station
hospital and the Bavarian Red Cross the
massive job of treating the more than
150 casualties begins everything that
can be done is done for the injured
before they are evacuated to these rear
areas which at this very moment are
setting up to receive them father John
Mellon of Brooklyn New York offers
comfort wherever he can
this bus ambulance of the US Army's 540
ninth medical company can carry as many
as 26 patients in addition to its
distinguished military history the 549
has participated in many civic affairs
all told over 100 vehicles are involved
in operations in cow 66 anyone anytime
anywhere this is the motto of the 420
first air ambulance company which
provided coverage by flying in supplies
and equipment and evacuating 24 of the
most critically injured within 90
minutes after it was sounded into being
operation sim cow 66 is completed
showing to the world that both nations
stand side by side and ready 24 hours a
day to extend themselves in the event of
an actual mass casualty
cup to France this quiet town like
others throughout France is destined to
know and even greater quiet as a direct
result of Francis new foreign policy us
installations are being closed at the
cup to ammunition depot a handful of
Americans remain to load ammunition from
storage key glues onto trucks for
transfer to installations elsewhere
despite the heavy investment that has
gone into them these buildings may never
be completed the last truck convoy moves
out leaving Cup to depo to history at
Brock on the story is the same
warehouses are emptied of their supplies
at the commissary equipment is
dismantled and removed heavier materials
such as tank transmissions or jeeps are
loaded onto flat cars the loaded trains
headies at the zoom on depo a similar
story even permanent fixtures are taken
from the building and a trace for boats
and assorted craft belonging to the
United States are being moved to ports
outside of France cross fo was the site
of an army hospital patients and
personnel have all departed at boo sock
once a bustling devil all that remains
or a few pol tanks a lone guard and his
dog replaces hundreds of French
employees for the people of France the
American soldier has gone
president lyndon b johnson arrives at
Fort Campbell Kentucky to present
military awards for heroism to Vietnam
veterans the president accompanied by
mrs. Johnson and their daughter Lucy is
greeted at the airfield major general
Ben sternberg commander of the hundred
and first airborne division is host to
the president a 21-gun salute for the
commander-in-chief the president troops
the line of the one hundred and first
airborne along with Army Chief of Staff
General Harold k johnson and general
sternberg in a ceremony attended by
thousands of visitors including many
notables the president presents the
awards for heroism the president then
witnesses a demonstration by the man of
the hundred and first the show includes
a demonstration of airborne firepower as
part of an air assault under simulated
battle condition
the helicopters ability to carry sling
loads is clearly demonstrated mr.
Johnson reflects his keen interest as he
inspects weapons and uniforms captured
from the Vietcong the highlight of the
day is the President's speech to the
assembled wrong I speak to you now as
the commander-in-chief of the best
military force our nation has ever
placed on the field of battle 300,000
Young America better trained better
equipped better supported than any who
have borne our colors of the past are
now engaged in combat in faraway Vietnam
great fighting units have been writing
military history out there as they did a
generation ago in Europe and the Pacific
the 1st Infantry Division the big red
one the 1st air cavalry the 25th
Infantry Division the 170 third Airborne
Brigade and the one hundred and first
airborne division never have the people
of this country had more justification
for pride are more reason to be grateful
and they have today because of men like
you go i honored respected man of the
hundred and first we have come here
today to salute you may we prove worthy
of the honor that you and your comrades
in arms are bringing to this great land
of ours God protect you thank you very
much
later the president and his family visit
with the disabled veterans of the
fighting in Vietnam
LBJ enjoys his piece of cake as he chats
with soldiers and other dignitaries with
the festivities at an end President
Johnson and his party returned to the
airfield for fort campbell's a memorable
occasion
you